what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with another installment of our
how to on a live superhero series which
is definitely advertiser friendly
YouTube it this is advertiser friendly a
promise it's okay
people know the superheroes aren't real
they're not actually real so we're not
actually harming people just in case you
don't know superheroes are pretend but
we are going to be celebrating the
Wonder Woman movie this week and
discussing what would happen if Wonder
Woman lifted Thor's hammer Mjolnir so
before we get started yes I know that
Wonder Woman has lifted Thor's hammer
before in the 90s Marvel vs. DC
crossover event and I even have a video
covering that series if you want to go
check it out but really while seeing
Wonder Woman lift Thor's hammer was kind
of a cool moment nothing really came of
it but she decided to battle storm with
the hammer would be unfair due to the
godlike powers that he gave her so she
puts the hammer down right before the
fight and then gets rekt which is kind
of a silly way it's silly wait for
things to end but nonetheless the
prospect of Wonder Woman wielding Thor's
hammer is an interesting one that could
produce a really good story but before
we get into our story as always we have
to discuss the powers that Wonder Woman
already brings to the table and then
look at what she would be capable of
after picking up Mjolnir after that we
can get into our story and finally we'll
conclude with how to analyze a hammer
wielding Wonder Woman so let's start
with Wonder Woman's powers and the first
thing I need to point out here is that
Wonder Woman is a very old character
really one of the original DC characters
going all the way back to the Golden Age
of comics in the 1940s and that means
that her powers and abilities have
undergone significant changes throughout
her lengthy history and so what we're
going to do in this video is focus on ur
powers as they currently stand in comics
since our story is actually going to be
set in a present-day status quo so and
Greg Rucka zr1 storyline during DC
rebirth it was revealed that Wonder
Woman derives her powers from a pantheon
of three gods and their animal forms and
were revealed to her as she needed them
and the first among these is revealed to
be the most iconic to her character a
force which is superhuman strength
swimming to point out here during year
one they showed up to her as animals
while she was being held so Wonder Woman
leaves the mascara right like she leaves
the mascara Paradise Island what
everyone called she shows up in like the
main DC landscape and she shows up in
the US and they're like hey we're gonna
have to hold you in stasis
you know hold you in like a holding cell
because we don't really know anything
about you we have to kind
figure out what's going on with you and
she's like okay it's cool whatever and
then like her friends coming to see her
the next day and like Steve Trevor and
everybody is like hey Wonder Woman how
are you doing she's like oh I'm doing
good you guys won't believe this I have
powers and they're like really how do
you know that she's like the woodland
critters told me so they showed up in
the middle of the night and told me that
I have powers and I was like okay I mean
it was like all right Wonder Woman you
got to go to the funny farm because you
are talking to woodland critters and
you're claiming that they gave you
powers but they actually did they gave
her powers which is really kind of cool
anyway this might seem like a pretty
standard set of abilities and perhaps
even somewhat generic but there are some
other aspects of our character that are
a little more unique
for example Wonder Woman's Amazonian
upbringing has molded her into one of
the most advanced fighters on the planet
when it comes to hand-to-hand combat as
well as combat with melee weapons
furthermore her fighting prowess is
bolstered even further by the
indestructible dauntless she wears that
are capable of deflecting bullets as
well as their signature weapons the
lasso of truth which forces anyone in
entangles to answer truthfully to any
question that they're asked so this
pretty much covers Wonder Woman but what
would happen if we add Neil near to the
mix well gulnur is one of the most
diverse and powerful artifacts in the
Marvel Universe and can perform a number
of diverse and impressive feats first
and foremost
Milner's capable of delivering
concussive blows that are able to cause
major destruction with adamantium and
vibranium really being the only two
substances that are able to withstand
blows from the hammer Mjolnir can also
project powerful energy blasts in a
variety of forms the first among these
is the God blast which converts the
divine energy within Thor into an energy
blast so strong that it caused Galactus
to run for his life and penetrated the
core of ego to living planet no joke
Thor use the god blast on Galactus and I
was like oh my god and it was like we
gotta go by Galactus base it was a fine
strength is one of the coolest moments
ever better any event the hammer can
also admit what's known as the anti
force which is not really explained very
well but is known to be capable of
destroying entire planet so Monier also
allows Thor to manipulate the weather
enabling him to produce powerful storms
lightning bolts and cyclones powerful
enough to lift buildings and of course
being made of uber metal Milner is
nearly industry
Cybil but the word nearly is extremely
important because we have seen a hammer
destroyed before which we'll get into a
little later during a how to kill
portion of this video but for now let us
get into the story as we seek to answer
the question what if Wonder Woman lifted
Thor's hammer and then actually kept at
this time so as I said earlier we are
going to be setting this story in the
present day comic continuity and if
you've been reading Thor at all you'll
know that there is an alliance that has
formed between Malekith and his Dark
Elves the frost giants and Loki who all
had basically allied themselves in hopes
of taking over the nine realms for those
guys who have seen my video on the
accursed that is how all that stuff
starts plus we have like Jane Foster
Thor and I think we've done War of the
nine realms I believe we've done that I
don't remember I've taught my head I'll
have to go and look because I haven't
looked yet
so our story opens with Malekith and
lafi the leader of the frost giants
discussing the whereabouts of Loki
laufey's annoyed that Loki is never on
time because you know it's lucky but
malakut tells him not to worry that
Loki's on a mission of high importance
one that will help them expand their
empire when we pan out we actually end
up seeing that the two of them are
actually talking in the throne room and
Asgard and it's revealed that they have
succeeded in taking over Asgard proper
we didn't get a flashback scene
explaining that they have basically
discovered the new Thor's secret
identity as being Jane Foster and then
apprehend her while she's doing anything
whatever it happens to be grocery
shopping at chemotherapy whatever the
case may be just like when she's in her
normal human form
Jane is imprisoned at Asgard by Loki
whose nature as a double agent is still
not widely known leading her separated
familiar and the citizens of Asgard
without of Thor to protect them as the
Odin son still believes himself to be
unworthy and therefore it cannot lift
the hammer without for fighting against
him and Odin having turned control of
Asgard over to his brother pool as he
stays by the side of his dying wife
Freya and is therefore not prepared for
battle the frost giants and Dark Elves
are able to overtake Asgard after a
lengthy battle that left Jane foster as
well as the Odin son Cole and Odin
himself prisoners of malakut and lafi
now we cut back to the conversation
regarding Loki and we end up finding out
that he's learned of a realm that had
hitherto been unknown to anyone in the
nine realms that was home to a great
race of warriors we also learned that
Loki has gone undercover to infiltrate
this realm and learn about its people in
hopes of either winning
to its side or in the alternative
finding a weakness that he can exploit
to take control of that realm as well so
then we cut to Loki infamous Kyra
undercover in his female form he's
running around as a chick look he's a
chick he's just like hey girls how's
everybody doing today just got back from
the store but anyway I can't believe I
just did that anyway he's undercover in
his female form and coming to the rulers
in hopes of forging an alliance lucky
tells Queen Hippolyta and Wonder Woman
that he's there on behalf of his people
who have overthrown the tyrannical
rulers and a rebellion to free
themselves from oppression locaton
Stacie's belief that the coup may be
short-lived
however since the overthrown dictators
were powerful godlike beings loki
implores that the Amazons enter into an
alliance with him and swear to aid them
should be as Guardians try to reclaim
their throne now Wonder Woman senses
something is amiss but not to alarm Loki
says that she'll accept his offer of an
alliance and will seal it with an oath
now as part of this oath ritual however
both of them will have to bind their
hands with her lasso now having no clue
what the lasso is Loki agrees and of
course ends up ensnared in the lasso of
truth which I would think would be
something amazing to be hoped Loki the
god of Lies tied up in the lasso of
truth Allison would that be just just
like asking some crazy thing like Loki
what's the craziest thing that you've
ever done and look he's just like ah I
don't know like give me a give me like a
really crazy thing that Loki would have
done like like post that down in the
comment section because I'm curious to
see like the craziest thing you guys can
come up with that Loki would do but any
event Wonder Woman coaxes the truth out
of Loki gets him to reveal his true face
and decides that something must be done
to aid the Asgardians so she decides to
lead a party of Amazon's into Asgard to
liberate the Asgardian prisoners with
Loki remaining and snared in the lasso
and telling them the way to Asgard now
once they arrive they engage the Dark
Elves and the frost giants in battle and
hold their own for a while but soon find
themselves overwhelmed desperate for a
way to gain the upper hand
Wonder Woman asked Loki how his armies
can be defeated compelled to tell the
truth Loki tells her that there is a
weapon that she can use in the armory
which he forces him to lead her to so
she opens the armoury and we see Mjolnir
sitting in the middle of the room a
Wonder Woman's all confused she's like
hammer and Loki's like yeah and she's
like you expect me to defeat a league of
Giants with a hammer I kind of feel like
that's how wonderful
would talk I mean it would be more
masculine but I'm afraid if I try to do
more masculine she would be like a dudes
this would be like a hammer and I have a
hard time believing whatever would sound
like a guy when she talks but look he's
like it's not just any hammer if you're
worthy there's nothing you won't be able
to do so Wonder Woman suspicious she
trust the power of her lasso and
believes Loki's words so she puts her
hand on the handle and lifts the hammer
into the air and we get like this iconic
image of Wonder Woman lifting that
hammer over her head and just being like
wow I don't know something along those
lines but she remarks on the power that
she feels flowing through her now from
here you can probably guess where this
is going like she just destroys Malekith
Elves and the frost giants and so
basically what we get is like this epic
battle sequence of Wonder Woman just
like crushing everybody I mean she's
just like hittin folks left and right
she's like you get some and you get some
and your kids some like everybody gets
some of the hammer whether they want or
not everybody gets a slice of that pie
she ends up just kind of wrecking
everybody with the hammer now naturally
all of the enemies have basically run
away and so Wonder Woman freezy has
Guardian prisoners including Jane Foster
who wonder woman learns had the hammer
prior to her imprisonment now we get a
brief conversation between the tooth and
Wonder Woman again remarks on how
powerful she feels and what she could do
with the hammer in her world and for a
minute we don't know if she's going to
relinquish the hammer now ultimately she
does decide to put the hammer down and
Jane picks it up to reclaim her statuses
for and Wonder Woman and the rest of the
Amazons leave with as God restored and
Loki in prison so the status quo is
restored and the good guys win and
everyone happy and no one is said just
like you guys like it right like you
guys like heavy and things you guys like
hitman like no one guys what what's that
you say Rob core you want to know what
happens if we have to kill her
Wow I'm glad you asked because now we
get to get into the part about killing
Wonder Woman it should become spork so
really we're going to have to do this in
two stages first we strip Wonder Woman
of Thor's power and then figure out a
way to kill Wonder Woman so the easiest
way to do this is to separate Wonder
Woman from the hammer and this is where
I mentioned earlier about mule near only
being nearly indestructible as far as
the Hammers durability goes now as we
have seen more than once in comics
Thor's hammer can be destroyed it has
been a few times it's been vaporized by
the molecule man Owen Reese it's been
blasted by a celestial and it's been cut
in half by
site of a dark god named paratus but
what will actually help us here is that
the hammer has also been shattered by
the metal weapons wielded by the frost
giants now since frost giants are
present here it's possible that they may
have uber weapons of their own and
smashed Mjolnir to thereby taking
away the power forward from Wonder Woman
now this strategy might also allow us to
kill two birds with one stone so to
speak as the instance in which manure
was destroyed in this way created an
explosion on par with an atomic bomb so
there's a strong chance that this
explosion could take out Wonder Woman
the other side of that however is that
the explosion also has a good chance of
taking all of us out as well
so that leaves us with more conventional
means of taking down Wonder Woman once
she no longer is in possession of the
hammer and one way we might be able to
do this believe it or not is by simply
shooting her now that might sound crazy
giving her insane level of strength and
durability and it might sound like a
lazy answer but the reason I bring this
up is that Wonder Woman's weaknesses in
modern interpretation of the comics have
not been very clearly defined however
one historical weakness it seems is that
she is vulnerable to any weapon that
could pierce her skin like a bullet now
I don't know if this weakness has ever
been explicitly stated but it has long
been assumed due to the fact that Wonder
Woman frequently uses her bracelets to
block incoming bullets so the logical
assumption is that bullets can harm her
otherwise why would she go through the
trouble of blocking them if that doesn't
work I think the only way to kill Wonder
Woman is to have her go up against
someone who is simply more powerful and
more durable than her and she doesn't
really have a weakness per se like there
doesn't seem to be anything that would
be Wonder Woman's kryptonite that would
just be the ultimate trump card to take
her out at least not that I could find
so for us I think our best bet is to
hope that we can get our hands on some
uber metal weapons to break the hammer
of four and then hope that we can
exploit one woman's perceived weaknesses
against piercing weapons if that doesn't
work we'd have to get some
super-powerful character like Superman
doomsday horses we're doing Marvel vs.
DC crossovers here like maybe The
Incredible Hulk
just to simply take her out in a fight
but let me know what you guys think down
in the comment section if you are new
here to come as explained make sure you
guys hit the sub button to become part
of the robb pork you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
I will catch you while later peace
[Music]
[Applause]